meaning Kimes ESPN senior writer she's
also got an ESPN daily podcast you can
see her on around the horn First Take
you can basically find her everywhere on
the mother ship I mean it thank you for
joining us under different circumstances
we'd be talking about this Super Bowl
but given your age you're there with
Kobe growing up with lb this is after
the Jordan era I know what Jordan meant
to me growing up and other players but
what did Kobe mean to you I think so I
grew up in Seattle and for me and I
think a lot of people my age tank Rafi
jr. was iconic in a sense that everyone
I knew wanted to be him basically we all
swung like him we tried to act like him
we were you know cap backwards like him
and I think Kobe kind of occupied a
similar place in a sports imagination
for people of my generation where
everyone I knew just kind of wanted to
play like him and act like him and be
like him more than Jordan for kids my
age yeah and that's what I was wondering
about because you know his be like Mike
and then Ken Griffey junior came in and
you know he had his presidential
campaign likely they become a lot larger
than life and then when they lose their
life and then you try to put it in
perspective and that's that's the hard
part with a day like today like how do
you pay tribute in a way because I said
you can mourn but you celebrate but how
do you do how do you judge you know how
do you juggle that fine line so for me
yesterday flying into Miami landing on a
plane from Los Angeles everyone getting
the news at the same time and sort of
reacting with shock that hit me really
hard but I think what sort of I don't
want to say broke me because that feels
a little overly dramatic but really
stung me was seeing how old his daughter
was seeing 2006 through 2020 like that's
those are not numbers you should ever
see together in that context right you
saw the Kobe his year in memoriam r.i.p
but when I saw it applied to his 13 year
old daughter it just kind of shook me to
my core and really
made me think about in the way that
death often does it kind of makes you
think about your own life and your
relationships and how it feels so up
Cystic but how do I relate to this
person how does this person's life and
death affect me I think seeing that
really made me reflect on my own
relationship with my father I'm a sports
writer because of my dad like a lot of
women who work in sports because we had
a similar relationship where he pushed
me and sort of you know transferred his
passions to me which was football in my
case and I think yesterday seeing all of
the remembrance about particularly their
relationship caused me to reflect on
that to reach out to my own dad and just
think about where we came from as well
yeah it's interesting that you bring
that up because I immediately thought of
my three daughters they're now Rita now
they're in their 20s they're now asking
me about sports because growing up they
never did they just they but now they
want to know about sports and I go there
you know my one daughter is like now
tell me everything I need to know about
the Super Bowl dad I go no no honey you
got a little bit homework first and then
come back jump right I tried to and then
she goes so Patrick mahomes is good
right and I go yeah okay yep we got a
starting point here that relationship
though with with your father is powerful
and it still goes on and that's why you
know when you see a 13 year old and what
she was to him like she was an extension
of him and and he I think fell in love
with basketball again because of her and
to go to those Laker games because she
wanted to go I think he had a sense to
that she would not only carry on his
legacy but sort of exceed it in some
ways no you know and not maybe not as a
player maybe as a player but also as
someone who could be really important to
the women's game and again not to bring
it back to my own experience but you
know growing up I remember my dad
explaining to me very basic football
terms to get me into it
you know his sort of distorted view of
the game which was that running backs
were everything and you know old school
football all the kind of dad stuff you
learned and now he has to ask me
constantly for questions about things
that are happening in football and
changes in the game and it's a lot of
fun you're far more knowledgeable than
your dad yeah yeah how would you
describe your fandom though because when
you're on with Dan Levitt our tour
around the horn it feels like if they
can bring back a clip of you as a
Seattle fan they they are quick to do
that to embarrass you
right I know they like to surprise me
with the interception which I'm
basically numb to at this point like it
does it just washes right over me you
know but yeah we had Russell Wilson's
mental coach on last week oh yeah yeah
Trevor Mullen and he said that they
watched he said at the time of that
interception 124 million people were
watching it and so his job after that
was to get together with Russell and get
every comeback that Russell ever had
from high school college in the NFL and
they watched it over and over and over
do you need Trevor to help you get over
Russell Wilson moment someone to
immediately play the highlights of your
life for you right yeah or to like
Google yourself and see the nice things
people have said about you or something
like that perhaps you do that no of
course not if you're going around the
horn in one of those shows do you look
at Twitter and what they say
um well fortunately it's pre-taped oh
like it's actually on I made the mistake
once of looking at my mentions during
First Take which is live and I read this
before
I wasn't debating Stephen a thank
goodness in this case because I check my
mentions and of course there was some
first take in particular it brings out a
certain sort of audience so when it came
back from break because I again had
foolishly this was like early at ESPN
one of my eyelashes looked like a
caterpillar
because the tears had loosened it from
my eye which didn't also didn't help so
ever since that experience I never look
at what people especially not live
because you can't do that no no and I
always tell the dinettes don't tell me
like I don't know no no they read it I
don't want to know it because you can't
only if we've made a mistake do I want
to know it you know I have to clarify
something but I don't care I just I
don't because it it'll affect you can
get 9 people saying oh you're wonderful
that one person who says right that's
all you know you're over the hill what's
wrong with you Oh women carried you all
those years like you know oh this summer
I had a chance to do color commentary
for the Rams preseason which of course
is long live and I was very nervous and
then I checked it and it was a bunch of
tweets all from my mom all right this is
preseason football like it's they're not
my mom is probably the main audience
right now in preseason how do you come
up with the topic or Ghandour guest for
your podcast for the Daily Show yeah
we're really lucky because we have so
many people who work at ESPN and we can
lean on them around the clock especially
when something like Kobe's death happens
we had Ramona Shelburne on today who had
a personal relationship with Kobe wrote
about a wonderful story about him in
2016 during his final season and so we
usually decide a couple days in advance
you know we had a whole slate of Super
Bowl shows planned that something like
Kobe happens and kind of throw it out
the window and start over which happens
a lot in sports I am friends with
Shelley Smith and Shelley went through
cancer and she covered the Lakers for
ESPN and she Kobe stopped talking to her
after the trial in Colorado said didn't
like the way she was reporting on and
she went through chemo lost all of her
hair and then she was going to show up
for media day and people said you know
maybe Kobe will talk to you now and
Shelley wasn't sure and then sure enough
Kobe came up you know put his arm around
her and said you know
she said hey I missed this and you could
tell where you know what happened and
that compassion where that is one thing
but this is somebody who's trying to
live and you know I think Shelley was
always appreciative of he was
competitive and how people were covering
him in Colorado but there was also
compassion that was deep down and you
didn't always find that with him and
same with Michael Jordan even Tiger like
there's a certain mindset of to be great
and then you know what are the
casualties with that greatness you know
and I that's where I loved seeing him as
a family person with his daughter I
think that's the great thing about
covering athletes over the course of
their entire career so many of them we
meet them when they're like teenagers
right I mean I thank God every day no
one knew me when I was injured and so we
see them go through so many different
phases you know some good some bad some
really bad in their lives but also as
journalists we try to have the capacity
to mark change and observe it and I
think commemorate it when it happens
it's great to see we appreciate you
stopping by each day Mina has a guest
then you discussed the most unique
compelling stories it's the ESPN daily
podcast available for download on ESPN
Spotify Apple podcast also on highly
questionable around the horn first tag
what do you want today I love that tell
your husband I said allo and she
survived the Leba tarde wedding as well
right what I remember of it yeah exactly
mean it comes from the mothership for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]